okay so this is what I want to do and
again they're giving you a point here
some questions there weren't they won't
do that they will I find an
approximation okay how do we go about
finding the base some roots somewhere
and then use Newton's method to get
closer to it think about it if if they
didn't if I didn't tell you that there's
going to be a root near x equals one
okay how would you go about the Tony
okay what's a good starting point yeah
think about it after I run through this
dear ball I'll tell you but you see if
you can come up with there's at least
two ways I can think of but you guys
know one one quite recent one a bit
further back though you guys know about
graphs and their properties that'll let
you try and work out a guess okay anyway
let's get going if I'm going to use
Newton's method I've got the function
but I also need its derivative right
because otherwise I won't be able to
evaluate this okay so this so therefore
after Ashley is that okay so that's good
now my first guess is x equals one right
so therefore I go straight to saying
well what will be X gets big and he's my
he's my thing which you want to put a
big you know colorful rectangle around
it I'm just gonna recite this okay so
it's going to be next one which is 1
minus F of 1 on F dash
so you probably to be honest could get
you calculator to do this but you know
it's not that hard of a function so
let's just do it all right
yeah 3/4 okay so that's alright that's
good can we go further how do we do the
next one exactly the same way we do this
one right so x3 we got my second guess
for you x3 is X 2 minus f of X let's see
3/4 minus 3/4 cubed what's that ok so
you probably want to get your calculator
out at this point but I'm stuck writing
it so what do I got 64 plus 3 times what
do we actually get once again six six
and on what stuff after that well that's
yeah ok now you can see you can keep
going right yeah I'm curious you do it a
couple more times right at what point
can we say you know I have this is this
is point seven five right at what point
can I say with confidence I have one
decimal place of accuracy or two or
three okay you finish up those steps now
has anyone thought if I didn't provide
you with an initial guess how might you
go about it how much okay
that's a good place to start well forget
about all this approximation in that
kind of thing right you guys can
probably graph this without too much
difficulty at least approximately right
but when you do say R now don't worry
about finding the root because who knows
what the room because the cubit okay so
think back to you know your 10 version
of you how would how would they he-she
go about graphing this what would you do
reven your 11 version of G your 11 you
knows way there are stationary points
right
well at least roughly you're gonna have
what kind of shape you gonna get okay so
if you know where stationary points are
let's just think of any kind of cubic
right suppose you have this kind of
shape yes now you can find out where
these points maha right and because it's
a cubic that means that these points are
gonna to solve these ones you're gonna
have a quadratic you can solve
quadratics that's fine okay so once you
know what this value is and this value
is you automatically know okay it must
be roots in between them right or at
least if it's a different kind of you
know cubic if you got something like
this right you find one here you find
one there well when you know what the
nature of each one is not okay am I
gonna guess this way or am I gonna guess
that way okay so that employed informs
your guests right for that for once we
usually do going to keep it again but
you don't need to be given one you guys
can work it out okay go back to
yesterday's question find the function I
gave you for bisection method and you've
already gotten to one decimal place
accuracy okay I've got a few more steps
get a bit more accuracy and then compare
Newton's method start at x equals 1 or x
equals 2
well okay so I didn't really I would
have given you some kind of accuracy so
I might were either sent using two
applications in a very similar way that
they would say use two applications or
citizens or they'll say get me to one
decimal place or two decimal places I
think this is already two missing pieces
but you can you couldn't 686 yeah did
you just not input it correctly oh how
much is era anyway okay that's fine I
didn't do anything so big
what's the next one actually I'm curious
to see you're all ready yeah okay so at
this point we're already two decimal
places
one application that's pretty good right
it took us two applications just to get
to one decimal point on the previous one
okay different questions will depending
on the kind of function yet and which
side your guess is all I kind of think
that determine how quickly like there's
no automatic after two steps you will
always be two decimal places something
like that just got tested